[Musik]
willkommen bei bild millionen deutsche
die echte existenzangst haben tausende
die wegen der energiepreise wütend auf
die straße gehen ein land das gerade
wohlstand verliert und politiker die uns
sagen dass wir lieber mal waschlappen
benutzen sollten als die dusche wie
konnte das alles so weit kommen heizen
verboten schafft deutschland sich ab
dass diskutieren wir hier in den
richtigen fragen mit thilo sarrazin dem
ex spd politiker errechnet mit der
politik jetzt ab zu viel ideologie zu
wenig sachverstand marcus faber
fdp-bundestagsabgeordneter warnt vor
panikmache und sieht die deutsche
energiepolitik auf dem richtigen weg
götz rupprecht ist bei uns kernphysiker
und unternehmer mit einer echten idee
nämlich eine mini reaktor der unsere
energieversorgung revolutionieren könnte
mehr dazu gleich und peggy lindemann ist
bei uns alleinerziehende mutter aus
schwyz drei kinder ein job der wackelt
denn in ihrer raffinerie in schwedt wird
putins gas verarbeitet und uns claassen
zugeschaltet langjähriger energie
topmanager er war chef von mbw und jetzt
sagt er die welt lacht uns alle aus
wegen unserer energiepolitik in allen
herzlich willkommen bei den richtigen
fragen frau linnemann kennen sie
existenzangst haben sie in diesen tagen
existenzangst ja doch schon meinen job
da steht ja schon um das spiel jetzt
wenn uns der erdöl hahn zugedreht wird
und auf halmen das kann man nicht und
dann natürlich auch weil alles teurer
wird die lebensmittel und ja die mieten
die gasanlage
was legen sie zurück wie bereiten sie
sich darauf vor auf den herbst auf dem
orange zurücklegen ich lebe gerade schon
von meinen ersparnissen muss ich sagen
dass an der stelle also sparen sparen
sparen energie sparen aber geld sparen
können sie gar nicht
wie spüren sie diese angst bereitet
ihnen das schlaflose nächte wie sprechen
sie mit den kindern darüber
ich habe tatsächlich schon vorräte
angelegt für den fall dass war eine
dunkel flotte haben und zwei wochen oder
so kein strom mehr kriegen public das
war für zwei wochen was zu essen haben
und einen kleinen gaskocher meine kinder
zeigen den vogel die lachen mich aus ja
aber wir werden ja sehen wie konnte das
in deutschland so weit kommen dass
jemand der arbeitet über zwei jahrzehnte
in der raffinerie in schwedt
alleinerziehende mutter mitten im
arbeitsleben hat angst um ihren kleinen
wohlstand hat existenzangst ja das ja
dass sie angst haben dass das ist zu
verstehen das ist ganz klar das hätte
ich auch in ihrer situation
letztlich muss ich muss sich die politik
fragen wie kann sie muss er immer fragen
wie kam es dort hin und wie kann man dem
einzelnen helfen dass man zwei
unterschiedliche erfahren ist redet aber
wie kam es dorthin hatten wir noch mal
die zahlen angeschaut ordnen sie mich
eingeladen hatten also der deutschland
hat ja beim beim bezug von erdgas
keinerlei preis der vorteile gehabt
gegenüber anderen ländern wir haben in
den letzten 15 jahren exakt das bezahlt
was andere auch zahlen das heißt wenn
wir unser wenn wir unser erdgas woanders
bezogen hätten in anderen strukturen wie
frankreich wie spanien wer andere länder
hätten wir das selbe gezahlt und hätten
jetzt keine not und hier hat wohl die
deutsche politik insgesamt versagt
nämlich alle die die
unkritisch eben gesagt haben na ja wenn
das gas aus russland kommt ist doch ok
und die leitung ist doch da und die wenn
schon nicht auf unser geld verzichten
die haben sich alle chöre das
aufzuarbeiten wochen eine eigene sendung
jetzt ist man da wo man ist und dann
sind nächste fragen was hätte die
politik tun können als der als dr also
ein marsch kam in die ukraine und da
muss ich sagen sie hatte keine andere
wahl als zu sagen mit diesem land dass
von diesem mann geführt für treiben wir
keine handel mehr alles andere wäre der
politik ganz unmöglich zu sagen sie
diskutieren wir hier noch anja huth und
sein und da weil ich bei dem dritten
punkt wie man mit der situation um geld
und da beginnt also meine kritik an der
augenblicklichen politik sie war davor
warnt vorfeld daran sind viele schuld
das ist vergossene milch und jetzt wäre
für mich ganz klar man muss ja muss ja
muss er also drei gruppen unterscheiden
jemand wie mich mit seinem
einfamilienhaus einem vernünftigen
provisions einkommen es ist natürlich
oft auch dann sehr ärgerlich wenn die
gasrechnung steigt aber es ist nicht
existenziell und ich muss deshalb auch
jetzt darauf nicht verzichten
und das gilt für also viele millionen
deutsche und am ganz unteren ende der
gesellschaft gilt für also sieben
millionen empfänger von grundsicherung
ist das auch nicht erzählt das hat der
staat letztlich das erdgas und in der
mitte ist eine gruppe für die ist das
existenziell und denen muss man helfen
und zwar
jetzt
wir haben 80 millionen deutsche ich
würde mal sagen zehn millionen mit 10
millionen also sieben millionen ganz
jetzt kann man den einkommen sieht a
landschaft ganz unten in der
einkommensskala grundsicherung dann also
zehn millionen das sind also das sind
jetzt wie sie die alleinerziehende mit
drei kindern kein so wahnsinnig hohes
einkommen das sind der rentner die kurz
über der grundsicherung liegen
es gibt viele viele unterschiedliche
fälle und da muss man helfen und so
helfen dass man die jetzt nicht am gas
sparen hindert also es ist falsch dass
gast subventionieren jeder soll
möglichst viel gas aktiv einsparen muss
ihnen helfen durch durch also durch also
allgemeine einkommens hilfen die kann
man das doch kann man einbauen ins
wohngeld das kann man einbauen in die
einkommensteuer lone star da gibt es
unterschiedliche wege ich würde sagen
eine familie iks die eben jetzt durch
benzin und energie im monat nach der 600
600 euro mehrausgaben hat da müsste man
eben sagen damit jedenfalls jetzt jetzt
meint wegen 50 prozent vom staat
abgenommen damit auch noch was übrig
bleibt damit auch das preis bleibt und
das geht nur durch absolute durch
einkommen zu helfen was jetzt passiert
mehrwertsteuer ich lass mir einen tiefen
hass ich habe wir haben in unseren in
unserem haus in der flotten burg 25.000
kwh verbrauchen sie hier und die werde
ich jetzt hat und jetzt halt ich
plötzlich stadt statt statt also 19 7
prozent sie war eigentlich nur eine
direkt im rhein so weit geht jetzt die
freundschaft nicht ich kenne ja noch gar
nicht aber ich würde mal sagen dass der
staat wie das gibt finde ich
einigermaßen claude denn ich hätte auch
wenn jetzt die preise steigen hätte ich
natürlich viel schimpft auf die politik
und dann lässt sich wieder was abgebucht
werden unter westers gewählt hat sich in
relativ geschenk für sie aber für frau
linda ist es ein bisschen ein größeres
geschenk und trotzdem erster staatsgast
beim lindner führt ist ja in der
staatskasse das geld das finde ich das
absurde java erwirtschaften geht doch
und genau wir sind ja
deshalb sag ich ja als wir wissen und
wird mit zahlen daher sagen wir ja sagte
er halte energie sauber an wenn ich wenn
ich meinen wenn ich jetzt im
finanzministerium stars ticket.de
gewesen wäre und mein minister hätte
raten könnte hätte ich gesagt herr
minister das wird alles ziemlich teuer
das kostet 46 78 milliarden euro aber
bitte lassen sie uns das doch an die
geben wenn das geld schon weg ist wie
ist wirklich brauchen und nicht an die
die es nicht brauchen
das wirst du doch irgendwie gemeinsam
hinkriegen und das ist was ich an der
augenblicklichen politik kritisieren
verstanden herr rupprecht sie sind
kernphysiker sie beschäftigen sich mit
alternativen in unserer im moment so
schwierigen energiekrise aber wenn sie
jetzt die worte von herrn sarrazin hören
auch diese zahl die hängenbleibt 10
millionen die das betrifft die
tatsächlich jetzt berechtigte
existenzängste haben wegen der
gestiegenen energiepreise vor allen
dingen gaspreise was empfinden sie dabei
ist geht tief in die mittelschicht rein
dieser existenzangst völlig richtig und
er sarrazin hat sogar noch einen
wichtigen punkt vergessen es sind ja
redet ja jetzt nur sie haben wir von dem
privathaus
das ist ja sozusagen das das ende der
förderung man da etwas träge ist ja noch
eine ganze industrie die kommt noch dazu
und das wirkt sich ja auch wieder auf
preise aus letztendlich die man hinter
meine drei
private also wenn sie sich irgendwas
neues kaufen auch notwendiges gerät
vielleicht oder auch jetzt sogar wenn
sie treffer sind also für den notfall
jetzt noch was einkaufen würde auch
alles teuer und das bleibt letztendlich
alles an den verbrauchern hängen also
dass herr sarrazin hat angedeutet hat
eine lange vorgeschichte eigentlich und
das ist jetzt der vorläufige endpunkt
von sie eindruck dass das bei der
regierung schon angekommen ist diese
tatsächlich existenzielle angst dass man
sich nicht mehr damit beschäftigen muss
vielleicht ein paar prozent
mehrwertsteuer zurück zu schenken
sondern das ist hier tatsächlich um ein
abrutschen wie er sarrazin sagt von
millionen menschen aus der mittelschicht
aus der mittelschicht gehen ja also wir
es vielleicht auch nur arriva wurde der
12 da muss man sich fragen aber ich
frage auch nicht ob das jetzt ein
totales abrutschen ist aber es ist ein
prozess natürlich und ich finde es
eigentlich doch wichtiger zu sagen dass
die ursachen nicht bei putin das ist sie
die letzte konsequenz ja aber die
ursachen liegen tiefer und die liegen in
einem wandel der ganzen
energieversorgung in den letzten
jahrzehnten man hat eben auch sehr
einzelne
energieformen gesetzt und wollte das
durch gas ausgleichen und hat sich
darauf verlassen dass putin schon
liefern wird und das ist jetzt eben der
punkt wo man sich eben nicht mehr sicher
ist ob putin liefert sogar trump hat ja
davor gewarnt ja oder sagen dortige
außenminister heiko maas mit drin in der
vollversammlung hat hat er ausgelacht
wer in der tat und die region ist ganz
wesentlich verantwortlich die alte
regierung und jetzt aber eben auch die
neue regierung an dieser energiekrise an
dieser gas krise ist nicht nur putin ist
im wesentlichen die politik sagt herr
rupprecht naja verantwortlich für den
krieg gegen die ukraine ist einer der
diktator im kreml die gaskrise dennoch
um die gas und wie viel herr putin durch
die pipeline schickt das entscheidet er
offensichtlich auch selber sie haben
sich abhängig gemacht die regierung hat
sich abgehörten alte eigentlich moniert
sicher regierung derzeit noch gas man
hat nicht genügend alternativ sie werden
mich er auch nicht hören dass ich die
alte regierung verteidigen das werde ich
hier ganz bestimmt nicht tun ich glaube
es ist jedem klar dass deutschland sich
zu einseitig abhängig gemacht hat von
russischem gas und das ist über viele
viele jahre und jahrzehnte schief
gelaufen und die jetzige regierung hat
die aufgabe mit dieser situation
umzugehen wir haben eben schon gehört
handel mit dem reduzieren der sehr
nachbarland überfallen hat und das ist
der weg die frage ist nur wie schnell
kann man diese strukturen umbauen denn
so ein lng terminal entsteht eben auch
nicht in vier wochen die frage ist macht
die regierung jetzt genügend um eben die
versorgung der bürger den wohlstand der
bürger zu sichern herr sarrazin ist dass
ihr eindruck also letztlich muss ja man
muss unterscheiden was habe ich jetzt
als als eine verteilungsfrage und das
muss vernünftig geregelt werden ich
warte ab was da rauskommt es ist
jedenfalls keine gute politik alle 14
tage irgendein anderes instrument zu
haben was immer am ziel vorbei geht da
wird das prinzip preis ermäßigt
vereinigt das zentrale problem da kommt
das dann ein euro ticket freue mich für
jeden der billig bahn fährt war aber
nicht das zentrale problem zusätzlichen
bahn fahrten jetzt anzuregen in dieser
lage und jetzt kommt wieder etwas und
ist auch nicht das zentrale problem und
irgendwann fühlt sich jeder bürger
veräppelt sagt wenn die so viel für
einen so viel geld für dinge haben die
gibt es eigentlich gar nicht nötig sind
könnten sind eigentlich auch mal was für
mich haben und das und das sorgt dann
für einen unmut die man dann auch wieder
rational beherrschen muss und dann wird
das vierte fünfte sechste instrument
kommen und das ist natürlich ein
absoluter irrweg man muss jetzt zwei
fragen lösen sie löse ich das einkommens
problem
einer bestimmten gruppe 8 bis 5
millionen menschen schätze ich mal und
und wie gehe ich um mit der
versorgungslage auch neben dem wir jetzt
geld geben hilft ja nichts wenn die wenn
die wohnung kalt bleibt und im übrigen
wir haben auch schon also camping
gaskocher noch aus alten kempten im
keller mit diesen mit diesen blauen mit
diesem blauen patronen den haben wir
jetzt
also schon mal zu mal überprüfte ob wir
noch funktioniert und er tut ist so das
ist also schon mal beruhigen und da
stimmt man sich sowas hin da kann man
das ehrlich gesagt kann ich
gerade ruhiger
aber jetzt und jetzt diese
versorgungslücke wenn die auf uns
zukommt und da warte ich wirklich auf
eine antwort der politik dem mir fehlte
auch mangels lach nähe ganz oft mussten
in meiner gegenwärtigen weil ich jetzt
wie ich das beantworten soll was
passiert denn wenn jetzt irgendwann
mitte september das gas ganz hört auf zu
laufen da kommt die industrie gebraucht
ihre prozesswärme da kommen die privaten
haushalte da sage ich wieder um einen
alten vorschlag pullover anziehen 15
grad aber wer das nicht tut dann weiter
mit 21 grad heißt hier können wir auch
nicht daran hindern so und wie geht die
politik mit dieser süd vorführung das
ganz einfach wie die politik mitunter
sarrazin die gibt der uns nämlich
einfach ratschläge wie wir sparen können
wie kommt es bei ihnen zb an frau
lindemann wenn sie dann haben sie jetzt
ein kretschmann hören der sagt 'mensch
frau lindemann nehmen sie doch nach
schlappen sie müssen nicht so auf
duschen genau finde ich total schön war
ja habe ich was hat ihnen betrifft ja
überhaupt nicht erfriert nicht er wird
nicht frieren er hat ja auch den orient
sagte er auch so offen aber nehmen sie
jetzt öfter den waschlappen
in hamm war anscheinend gewählt habe ich
so festgestellt nate findet eine
katastrophe und auch die sanktion finde
ich scheiße die helfen weder der ukraine
noch hört er kriegt dadurch oft wenn wir
sprechen nur uns eigentlich schaden wir
nur unserem volk ein schwachsinn ich
möchte gerne weiter laufen lassen sind
gas und rohöl und da sehen immer mehr
deutsche sowie auch eine umfrage vom
freitag von den kollegen von rtl zeigt
anlass war die äußerung von wolfgang
kubicki der sagt mensch ich habe die
lösung lass einfach nur zwei jetzt
aufmachen das sichert unsere
gasversorgung das ist ihr parteikollege
gruppe ist ein parteikollege ja an
kubicki kann man auch daran erinnern
dass 80 prozent von nord stream 1 gerade
nicht genutzt werden das weiß er wir
haben keine pipeline problem ist ja
jetzt nicht so dass er das nicht wüsste
nur wird sie können ihn gerne fragen wir
haben gefragt haben er weiß dass das ist
folgendes ja wir haben keine pipeline
problem die kapazität ist sie auch jetzt
schon da wir haben am anderen ende der
pipeline ein problem und das ist
derjenige der nicht genug gas durch
liefert denn deutschland hat ja keine
sanktionen wenn es um den import von gas
gibt sondern offensichtlich nur wenn es
um die sache lieber herr rupprecht
würden sie das als eine lösung schritt
da vorne sehen nord stream zwei
aufmachen und zu sagen okay wir
verabschieden uns davon volle
solidarität mit der ukraine zu üben ja
wir gucken auf uns auf unsere
gasversorgung immer mehr deutsche sehen
das ja offenbar so also ich weiß jetzt
auch nicht genau was einem anderen seite
einer anderen seite der leitung ist es
war ja die turbine angegeben worden bei
nordstream einst als ursache dass man
jetzt nicht genug liefern kann mag
richtig sein kann ich nicht beurteilen
sie wurde jetzt geliefert da gab es dann
auch wieder irgendwelche schwierigkeiten
ich weiß nicht ob bei nordstream zwei
jetzt eine andere turbine schon
bereitsteht ob das so weit fertig ist
dass man dann wieder mehr durch pusten
könnte davon verstehe ich also weiß ich
wirklich nicht dann holen wir ein
hinzu in unserer sendung der ganz lange
top energiemanager war utz claassen der
bei mbw der chef war große herzlich herr
klaas wenn wir das hören und wir
sprechen jetzt über die äußerung von
herrn kubicki nord 72 einfach
reinzuholen sie als top energiemanager
würde dass uns die gasversorgung mit
blick auf herbst und winter sichern
also bin ich das was er gesagt hat zu
grunde liegen ein weil es ja erst mal an
der grundsätzlichen bereitschaft der
ehemaligen oder gegenwärtigen
vertragspartner aus russland gas zu
liefern nicht zwingend etwas ändern
würde und ich frage mich eigentlich was
sind wir eigentlich
energiewirtschaftlich für ein land
geworden wenn wir heute
sozialpolitisch
energiepolitisch
industriepolitisch
zitternd
abhängig sind von der frage wie eine
einzige person ihre gaspolitik
disponieren mag und man muss das war in
der härte sagen
klar hat das was jetzt erleben massiv
mit der situation in russland in der
ukraine und diesem furchtbaren
krieg zu tun aber es hat vor allem auch
damit zu tun dass bei uns über jahre und
im grunde jahrzehnte hinweg alle
vernunft in der energiepolitik
ausgeklammert worden ist es gibt kaum
einen bereich der politik der sich so
naturwissenschaftliche analyse physiker
physikalischer mathematischer logik
erschließt wie die energiepolitik und es
gibt kaum einen bereich in dem
mathematisch physikalische gesetze und
auch der gesunde menschenverstand über
jahre so mit füßen getreten worden sind
das wall street journal hat unlängst
gesagt dass deutschland klar ist die
energiepolitik der welt betreibt die
vernunft verantworten hat eingehen oder
sich einst anhängen wozu eben gerade zu
dem thema was schlappen wie haben sie
menschen in wird man in laos in
kambodscha wo heute ein zwei mal drei
war duschl am tag dort ist erklären dass
wir aufgrund eigenen
energiewirtschaftlichen versagens uns
heute vom ministerpräsidenten eines der
wirtschaftlich erfolgreichsten
bundesländer empfehlen lassen müssen
nicht mehr zu fuß sondern den
waschlappen zu gewähren und fassen die
bitte an den kopf und dann muss man
wirklich sagen wir sind inzwischen
energiepolitisch zur lachnummer der welt
da muss man gleich nach kambodscha
fahren um leute zu suchen die oder zu
finden die sich da an den kopf fassen
die findet man auch in paderborn und
obama gehofft ihr herr claassen wir
haben gerade schon werden wir gesprochen
haben fotos aus der vergangenheit
gesehen auch von ihnen damals von der
hannover messe von ihnen mit gerd
schröder und wladimir putin sie haben
gerade gesagt vernunft fehlte und herr
sarrazin hat sofort gesagt in der runde
ganz genau ja vernunft fehlt in der
deutschen energiepolitik bedeutet das
aus ihrer sicht mit dem freund putin
mehr geschäfte zu machen wir das
vernünftig gewesen oder weniger
geschäfte zu machen
um 1 vernunft hätte für mich bedeutet
ein energiemix nicht von einzelnen
energieformen einseitig zu sehr abhängig
zu machen und wir haben uns ja in einer
doppelten form abhängig gemacht und das
ist völlig unabhängig von der frage ob
er putin ein feind oder ein freund wäre
für sie war das ein freuen uns sowohl
vom gas r klasse haben uns sowohl vom
gas für sie war das ein freund wladimir
putin meint für mich war das ein
freundlicher gast an unserem messestand
in hannover damals und wir haben damals
ein sehr vernünftiges gespräch geführt
er hat auf mich einen sehr intelligenten
eindruck gemacht die dinge die sich
danach entwickelt haben hat glaube ich
niemand seinerzeit so vorhergesehen aber
völlig unabhängig von der frage wie
freundschaftlich freundlich oder
unfreundlich der war oder ist ist doch
müssen wir doch feststellen wir haben
uns sowohl vom gas sehr einseitig
abhängig gemacht haben der versorgung
noch von einem einzigen land das macht
niemand normalerweise so aber wir haben
ja auch andere fragen in der
energieversorgung nicht vernünftig
geklärt wir wollen keine krone keine
steinkohle weil sie klima fehlt der ist
wir wollen keine frauen kohle weiß tätig
ist und jetzt
wir wollen herrn energie wollen wir auch
und ich die kubicki frage jetzt an sie
auch ganz schnell der klassen also nur
zwei öffnen oder geschossen lassen
ich glaube dass es keine keinen
wesentlichen einfluss haben wird auf die
situation der nächsten monat und der
nächsten jahre weil sie sagen ist ja gar
nicht klar ob der dann da gas durch
schickt deutet im moment nichts darauf
hin wir haben sie gerade gesehen da am
stand damals hannover messe sie haben im
grunde das von damals genau noch mal
zitiert damals haben sie gesagt hier bei
mbw befinden sie sich herr putin unter
freunden das war ihre formulierung
damals gar nicht um ihnen das heute vor
zu halten sondern um zu wissen wie
würden sie den man einschätzen also kann
man dem heute vertrauen mit blick auf
unsere gasversorgung oder total das
misstrauen
ich schätze ihn extrem intelligent ein
aber er hat ein völlig anderes handlungs
paradigma als wir und aus reinem
paradigma heraus was ja lautet der
verfall oder der niedergang der
sowjetunion als solche sei die grösste
geopolitische oder geostrategische
katastrophe des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
gewesen lässt sich entnehmen
welche bedeutung der territorialen und
anderen themen beim ist und aus reinem
paradis war aus seiner welt heraus
handelt er hoch rational wir haben es da
nicht mit einem verrückten zu tun aber
wir haben es jemand mit jemandem zu tun
der völlig anderen
oberziele völlig anderen ideologien
völlig anderen grundwerten und rum
vorstellungen solcher weise tun aber was
er tut ist innerhalb seines handelns
paradigmas nicht irrational und ich
würde jedem empfehlen nicht seine
intelligenz und möglicherweise auch
seine konsequenz zu unterschätzen
verstörung unsympathisch und das in der
jetzigen situation auch erscheinen mag
verstehen die leute das was herr
claassen gerade gesagt hat noch in
deutschland 24 februar begann der krieg
frau lindemann das ist jetzt fast auf
den tag genau sechs monate her und jetzt
gehen wir rein in den herbst und den
winter und wird mal den menschen bei
ihnen schwebt weiter sagen können wir
nehmen nicht putins gas wir betreiben
volle solidarität zumindest den worten
mit der ukraine und dafür verzichten wir
hier immer schön auch in schwedt auf
ordentlich wohlstand nicht verstehen die
nicht und dann gibt auch hier noch leute
die begreifen hat dieser krieg gar nicht
erst im februar angefangen hat sondern
schon jahre zurückliegt ist ja ein us
geschichte das hat ja eine feuchte sind
nicht erst im februar begonnen die
straße jeden montag für die straße jeden
montag aus dem ozean und aber schon
stehen die dass hier herr rupprecht
vollständig sind sie auch auf der straße
jetzt wegen energie demonstration nicht
aber es gibt auch andere gründe aber ich
bin nicht so der demonstrations- typ ich
arbeite etwas anders
montagsdemonstration wegen der
energiekrise das ist etwas was sich
gerade aufbaut in deutschland herr
sarrazin das wird eine neue bewegung
eine art energie päda ja also letztlich
muss die muss die politik damit umgehen
sie hätte es ahnen können am 24 februar
damals war es ja klar man hat sich dazu
entschieden ich sage ich fand diese
entscheidung damals richtig mit putin
mit diesem land treiben wir keinen
handel mehr so lange mit diesem krieg
weiter schüren so damit war klar und ist
seit einem halben jahr klar dass wir den
risiko ausgeliefert sind das wenn es
putin gefällt die gaslieferung
vollständig aus und ich habe den
eindruck dass wir uns bisher auf dieses
auf dieses risiko bei den
verantwortlichen stellen am ende die der
bundesregierung und die und ihre und
ihre behörden nicht ausreichend
vorbereitet haben sondern es herrscht
ratlosigkeit auch bei mir ich versuche
ja parallel mitzudenken ich sehe zum
beispiel natürlich können können private
haushalte theoretisch 20 30 prozent
einsparen aber wie will man das
kontrollieren wenn jemand sagt ich bin
eben ich bin eben war michelle und durch
der wahl kann ihn nicht daran hindern ja
wie sie hatten aus der stadt so wüst
künftig möglicherweise aussehen dunkle
innenstädte arms brandenburger tor er
sowieso eher dunkel wir schalten die
straßenlaternen apero precht ist dass
das szenario was überhaupt nicht von
entfernen ist ja wir lassen das ist an
sich ein blackout war ganz klar aber ich
frage mich auch mal aber gibt's die
hatten ja und natürlich gibt's die
gefahr also das ist ja ganz anderes
thema eigentlich das ist die gefahr
eines stromausfalls durch die ganzen
verfehlung der energiewende ja und durch
das vermehrte einspeisung von volatilen
energie und ja durch die hoffnung dass
man das alles durch gas abfedern kann
und aus der kohle auch noch aussteigen
will und dann auch noch die kernkraft
abschaffen japanischen kunden würden sie
sagen wenn ihr uns team verstanden habe
zu wenig vernunft viel zu viel ideologie
ihr mann hätte ja man hätte ja ganz
einfach mal nachdenken können ich habe
mir wie gesagt die zahlen noch mal
angeschaut und es ist interessant im
jahr 2004 liefern noch der ganze
deutsche kernkraftwerke und parken und
der ganze deutsche park an der
kernkraftwerken brachte damals so viel
energie also soviel twh
auf die rolle wie heute die gesamte
sonnen und windenergie zusammen die
gesamte sonnen und windenergie die wir
im augenblick einsätzen in deutschland
reicht gerade mal aus um den ausfall der
der kernkraftwerke auszugleichen völlig
absurd wie notstromaggregat zu hause
nicht nur einen gaskocher sondern nummer
1 habe ich nicht ich bin optimist und
meine frau sagt immer das geht doch
nicht gut müssen etwas tun ich
das ja ja ja ich sage wenn wenn der wenn
der strom dauerhaft ausfällt dann
beginnt der bürgerliche zusammenbruch da
kann man an keiner kann man an keiner
tankstelle tanken dann kann man kann man
in denen der krankenhäuser nicht mehr
operieren dann kommen die gangs auf die
straßen in den in den in den also
kaufhäuser funktionieren die kassen
nicht mehr das heißt
dass das ist das bürgerliche ende von
deutschland wenn der strom länger als
eine halbe stunde ausfällt ein regional
oder überregional und das kann und wird
nicht passieren dagegen ging eine frau
im speicher zusammengenommen klar diese
30 minuten vielleicht gerade so noch
überbrücken ja genau sollte sarrazin
besser auf seine frau hören in der frage
also ganz viele deutsche machen das ja
so und freundinnen man lacht im moment
noch aber ganz viele deutsche kaufen
sich notstromaggregate kaufen sie hat
moment holzöfen für zu hause sorgen vor
rache schaffen sich vorräte an und
solche dinge meinung auch das ist für
keinen kamin heuer also ja zu
das aggregat auch kein haus aber ich
spiele immer häufiger mit dem gedanken
und vor kurzem habe ich mir so eine
trockentoilette bestellt meine freundin
auch denn das ist das problem ja dass
dann auch die spülung nicht mehr richtig
funktioniert erster zu führen nicht mehr
funktioniert und so weiter herr faber
die regierung hat durchaus dazu
aufgerufen
notstromaggregate eben sich zu besorgen
haben sie auf den rat von herrn beck
gehört ich habe mir kein
notstromaggregat gesucht über orco holt
gekauft ich habe aber vor einigen jahren
das buch blackout gelesen hast genau das
szenario beschreibt dass er sarrazin ja
gerade aufgeführt hat das eben sehr sehr
viel auch an der energetischen
versorgung hält deswegen muss man als
regierung jetzt eben auch alles mögliche
tun um die energieversorgung auch die
stromversorgung zu sichern sie schlagen
wir jetzt freidemokraten zum beispiel
vor über den winter auch die kernkraft
fertiger laufen zu schlagen ist immer
schlecht als regierungen sondern einfach
mal durchsetzen einfach machen das
vorschlagen dauert ja schon lange wissen
selber dass man drei koalitionspartner
haben ja herr sarrazin sagt die dem
entgegensteht sprechen wir gleich und
vor allen dingen machen wir nach einer
ganz kurzen pause einen echten
lösungsvorschlag der kommt von görtz
rupprecht unserem wissenschaftler
unserer physiker in der runde der ganz
bescheiden ist habe ja tatsächlich ein
lösungsvorschlag bietet der hoch
spannend ist das gleich hierbei bild
nach einer ganz kurzen pause
zurück bei wählt die richtigen fragen zu
großen energie zu großen gaskrise heizen
verboten schafft sich deutschland gerade
ab das ist unsere frage hier in den
richtigen fragen und packe lindemann ist
bei uns zu gast alleinerziehende aus
schweren job auch wackelt wegen dieser
gaskrise weil sie eben in schwedt in der
raffinerie arbeitet wo putins gas
verarbeitet wird die regierung hat und
öl vor allen dingen genau jetzt hat die
regierung natürlich wie jeder andere
auch geschworen den schaden vom
deutschen volk abzuwenden wenn mir jetzt
auf die aktuelle energiekrise schauen
ist ihr eindruck dass die region
tatsächlich alles tut um schaden
abzuwenden mir gar nicht ins gegenteil
ist der fall ich habe so das gefühl die
haben eine andere agenda die da
verfolgen
die versuchen gerade unser land zu
ruinieren ohne witz das ist rügen haben
wirklich so eine aussage schon öfter mal
getätigt dass die ja auch habe katja
auch selber mai sagt das deutsche volk
hasst er kann mit dem deutschen volk
nicht anfangen ja und gerade das ist ein
harter vorwurf aber was antworten sie
ich bin nicht hier habe ich nicht und
ich hatte auch nicht und meine eigenes
volk aber sie arbeiten natürlich mit
herrn harbeck zusammen der vorwurf
trifft ihn hart und das ist ihr
regierungspartner ihr koalitionspartner
ich bin mir sicher dass auch herr habe
ich daran arbeitet dass in diesem winter
niemand frieren muss und ich halte es
allerdings auch nicht für sonderlich
sinnvoll dass man den bürgern
empfehlungen gibt wie sie bitte zu
duschen haben sondern aufgabe von
politik muss es sein gesamtstaatliche
lösung zu entwickeln
da hat der wirtschaftsminister eine
tragende rolle und ich habe auch die
hoffnung dass er das auch versteht auch
wenn es jetzt noch warm ist dass wir so
wenig gas wie möglich nutzen sollten um
strom damit herzustellen sondern eben um
im winter heizen zu können und deswegen
zum beispiel die atomkraftwerke aber wir
haben wahnsinnig viel gas verströmt in
den vergangenen wochen in den
vergangenen monaten übrigens so viel wie
noch nie ausgerechnet jetzt und in
dieser krise wird uns gesagt wie es
fehlt an gas wir können möglicherweise
im winter im herbst nicht mehr die
wohnung heizen sei es in schwedt oder
woanders in deutschland das muss jemand
auf der straße erst mal verstehen er
sagt ja vor allem muss man erst mal muss
man erstmal die mathematik
nachvollziehen wenn wenn wenn er
bundesminister etwas sagt gehe ich erst
mal davon aus das ist wahr und ich habe
mein haar werk so verstanden mehreren
äußerungen dass es gar nicht ankäme auf
die auf d also gaskraftwerke weil wir
hätten nur ein wärme problem das ist
natürlich falsch wenn man sich die
zahlen anschaut im letzten jahr wurden
der 15 prozent des gesamten der strom
einsatz des kamen aus erdgas und das
jetzt im augenblick auch das und sie
sagten gerade eben so recht das ist im
augenblick noch viel höher also wenn wir
wenn es uns gelingt das wie abartig
erdgas erdgas ersetzen durch atomstrom
ich will auch dafür dass wir diese drei
bereiche licht und kernkraftwerken wir
wieder anwerfen was wir auch möglich er
ja überhaupt kein problem und das werden
wir belogen ohne ende wegen
irgendwelchen angeblichen
sicherheitsvorschriften tatsächlich
könnten wir also 70 twh das ist eine
ganze menge das ist das was die
krankheit schützen da wie sehr brachten
die sehen könnten wir ohne weiteres
wieder ans netz bringen und nur nach dem
gerade er sagen sie ihm verzeihen sie an
wie sie gerade ihr buch cover da geht es
um die vernunft und ihre feinde und ihre
argumentation folgend ist jetzt das was
der einer vernünftigen energiepolitik
entgegensteht gerade und das was frau
lindemann auch anspricht eine ideologie
ja im tumor und inklusion ideologischen
denkt das ist mein untertitel und geriet
man typisch bei den grünen die ideologie
die ich ja gar nicht kritisiere es ist
ja ihre ideologie nicht meine also der
kernkraft muss weg unabhängig von den
kosten das ist ja das ausgangs das
ausgang rede der grünen und dafür nehmen
sie in kauf das lässt sich die gesamte
windkraft und und die gesamte
solarenergie nur dazu benutzt wird den
dänen der fortfall der von kernkraft zu
ersetzen
und jetzt in dieser lage ist es ihnen
auch wichtiger was die als kernkraft
abschaffung angeht recht für behalten
als die probleme für die menschen und am
energiemarkt zu lösen was am ende der
wirtschaft schadet was die menschen
schalten und was das muss natürlich
weltweit derart lächerlich werde da hat
ihren klassen gerade gesagt eine
langjährige enbw topmanager herr
claassen schnell zu ihnen zurück sie
sind uns zugeschaltet und die haben
gerade frau lindemann gehört die
aufgebracht ist die wütend ist die
enttäuscht ist von der bundesregierung
und sogar sagt die tut nicht alles was
sie geschworen hat nämlich unseren
wohlstand zu mehren die tut nicht alles
um unseren wohlstand zu sichern nach dem
was herr sarrazin sagt hat sie damit
recht
also dass man wann ich glaube man wird
man darf gar nicht ernsthaft darüber
diskutieren ob man die noch in betrieb
befindet sich im kernkraftwerke länger
laufen ist in der situation in der auf
grün ein grüner ministerpräsident
über das aufhören des busens nachdenkt
kann es gar keine alternative mehr geben
als jede energie die wir vernünftig
nutzen können um sicher nutzen können
auch zu nutzen deshalb die
kernkraftwerke müssen erstmal weiter
laufen gibt es gar keine alternative zu
zweitens wir brauchen sie ist ja
sarrazin vorhin gesagt hat einfache
umverteilungs mechanismen jetzt um die
ökonomisch am stärksten betroffenen zu
schützen
und wir brauchen nicht doppelt und
dreifach marktverzerrung mechanismen wie
eine gasanlage wo im grunde am ende die
noch am meisten gestraft werden die dem
wort des staates das russische gas
sicher am meisten vertraut sie sieht ich
nehme sie auch einmal ein hanser und
herr claassen sie als vertreter auch
wenn es so ein bisschen her ist der
energiebranche sie profitieren am ende
noch die energie branche profitiert
davon wie kann das sein dass deutsche
gaskunden im moment ein ausländisches
energieunternehmen retten müssen
verstehen sie das
man verstehe ich nicht und und und ich
bitte dich auch ich bin vor voll von vor
langer zeit in andere industriebereiche
gegangen und heute zwar immer noch im
bereich technologischer als substitution
der substitution von titan und magnesium
tätig aber ich bitte sie mich nicht für
die fehler der energiepolitik übrigens
während und nach meiner amtszeit in
der arena war glas neu war in der
energiepolitik die vernunft weitgehend
außer kraft
aber aber der mann der neben mir sitzt
der vertritt diese gas umlage markus
farbe also die koalition die trägt das
voll mit auch ihre fdp trägt das voll
mit erstaunen mich ein bisschen dass man
ein ausländisches unternehmen rettet ja
als finanzminister als auch gelbe
ampelkoalition dass man ausländische
unternehmen uni per rettet mit unser gas
umlage mit der gas umlage von frau
lindemann von der ruprecht von herrn
sarrazin von hinweisen ja aber hat diese
gas umlage vorgeschlagen das ist sein
gutes recht und sie sind
hinterhergelaufen lindner hat jetzt
gerade ankündigt dass wir die
mehrwertsteuer auf gas deutlich senken
und damit eben die finanzielle belastung
der bürger reduziert wer macht es war ja
als 100 euro für
600 euro gas umlage und dann
mehrwertsteuer können wir ein bisschen
mehr als 100 euro noch mal abziehen von
der von der senkung das ist so das
verhältnis ja also es bleibt ein
riesiger batzen gas umlagezahlungen der
gasanlage ist natürlich dass der
gasmarkt nicht zusammenbricht dass
anbieter nicht zusammenbrechen und dass
wir auch über diesen winter eine stabile
versorgung mit strom und wärme haben das
ist die zielstellung ist das so herr
claassen
könnte das genauso und ließ per pleite
geht wer das verkraftbar ist
uns glaube ich gerade doch da ist er
herr claassen wäre das war kraft weise
ja
ich werde nicht darüber spekulieren wer
pleite gehen darf oder nicht aber ich
möchte auf einen punkt hinweisen die
gasanlage ist schon ein zweistufiges
instrument denn statt dass der staat
direkt rettet lässt er die bürger
indirekt das schafft damit noch ein
bürokratiemonster der abwicklung als
drittes und als viertes weiter dann
selbst erkennt dass es so nicht richtig
korrigiert er dann über die
mehrwertsteuer wieder so wenn man
versuchen die ecke denken muss ist
glaube ich schon gesagt der mechanismus
an sich gar nicht vernünftig sein
sarrazin pflichtet sofort weise ja also
sagt man muss unterscheiden und die welt
zu retten ist aus meiner sicht
unvermeidlich weil weil weil sonst der
markt nicht funktioniert also da müsste
sich der bund beteiligen was er
mittlerweile auch hand ja und da sagt er
und dann habe ich jetzt eine beteiligung
und nun und umgebung 6 7 8 milliarden
euro beihilfe und ich bin sicher dass
auch die das auch die der eu diese diese
bei für genehmigen wird und dann kostet
das eben das geld und dann und dann kann
und da kann er weiter funktionieren aber
die frage dass wir uns per
funktionsfähig halten müssen damit der
gasmarkt funktioniert und so weiter ist
doch völlig unabhängig von der frage wer
dafür zahlt zahlen musste für den bund
der bund hatte offenbar auch genügend
geld 9 euro ticket mit polen geht also
der bund hat auch das geld unmittelbar
zu helfen aber was damit jetzt der
normale der normale bürger soll weshalb
ich dadurch begünstigt werde weshalb sie
dafür zahlen müssen das ist doch das ist
doch über wir haben anschlägen weil wir
haben jetzt 340 millionen nach palästina
überwiesen hilfe jetzt versteht auch der
normale mensch auch nicht mehr wie
sollte gürtel enger schnallen und wir
sollen frieren und wie soll man sich
nach einer 340 millionen nachdem york
skandal im kanzleramt das kommt
obendrauf ist aber ein anderes thema
nochmal vor lindemann aber natürlich hat
das wütend gemacht in dieser woche sie
sind so ein bisschen schmallippig
geworden an dieser stelle gas umlage sie
können es aus dem herzen heraus auch
nicht wirklich mittragen nicht frieren
und nicht im dunkeln sitzen ist die
zielstellung über den weg können wir
glaube ich streiten aber dieses ziel
haben wir gemeinsam und bei ihrem punkt
natürlich bin ich bin vizepräsident der
deutsch israelischen gesellschaft und
fand die reaktion auch nicht nur optimal
aber dass das ist sozusagen der ist ja
wie erpressung also entweder zahlen wir
das jetzt die gas umlage zahlen alle
haushalte alle gas haushalte das in
deutschland oder wir sitzen sozusagen im
kalten zu hause wir versuchen risiken zu
minimieren als staat soll wir versuchen
dass die abhängigkeit von russland zu
minimieren das hätte man schon viel
früher tun müssen hat die alte regierung
aber nicht getan jetzt tut man das beim
bau infrastruktur und man versucht
marktversagen zu verhindern und das ist
natürlich natürlich alles prozesse
gerade beim thema infrastruktur die
leider nicht von heute auf morgen
durchgeführt werden könnte es dauert
zeit danach erlebt jetzt die fehler der
vergangenheit wir haben darüber
gesprochen ob die regierung alles tut im
moment um den wohlstand der deutschen zu
sichern von frau lindemann zum beispiel
ob sie alles tut ohne ideologien die
energiesicherheit zu gewährleisten tun
sie in der regierung ihr finanzminister
die fdp alles um zur atomkraft
zurückzukehren
also wir jetzt vor demokraten tun das ja
ich bin nicht mitglieder bundesregierung
ich bin mitglied des bundestags sieht
schon alle wir als freie demokraten
haben uns dafür durch um eingesetzt die
region zu unterstützen das machen und
wir setzen uns auch dafür ein dass
deutschland diesen winter nicht im
dunkeln sitzt in dem man zum beispiel
die kernkraft so fortsetzt fakt ist aber
bisher nicht beschlossen in der
ampelkoalition dieser mann hier zu
meiner rechten girls rupprecht möchte
mehr kernenergie und nicht ausstieg aus
der kernenergie er hat eine echte idee
einen kleinen reaktor das müssen sie uns
erklären herum bricht was hat es damit
auf sich eher auf sich und wie könnte
das ein teil unserer zukunft in der
energiesicherheit in deutschland seien
ja die idee schon mittlerweile zehn
jahre alt und es hängt auch nicht so
sehr von der größe ab ob das nur ein
klein oder groß ist das kann man
eskalieren ich will es mal versuchen die
wesentlichen punkte zu beschreiben
dieser erfindung wir haben ja auch
patentiert hier sehen wir das
also was ich hier sehen ist der
reaktorkern wir nennen das dual fluid
reaktor oder die flut reaktor und mit
diesem reaktor system durch flut sind
wir in der lage
verglichen mit den heutigen
druckwasserreaktoren die ja nur fünf
prozent etwa von von den brennelementen
nutzen tatsächlich über längere zeit 100
prozent die kernenergie zu nutzen und
das bedeutet gleichzeitig auch weniger
abfall weniger nuklearen abfall und wir
erreichen dass durch ein system von
röhren wo keine festen brennelemente
mehr drin sind sondern in den röhren
fliesst flüssiger brennstoffe grob
gesagt flüssiges uran und das wird
umspült von blei und das beiträgt die
wärme weg wie groß ist das ding das kann
man
eigentlich mit der leistung ich sag
jetzt mal für berlin berlin zur
versorgung mit 15 gigawatt bräuchte man
einen reaktor so eine trommel zylinder
durchmesser und höhe drei meter 3 metern
das heißt mit dem geringen platz aufwand
wäre die großstadt mit vier millionen
jahre versorgung ist ein ziemlich hoher
energiedichte aber das kann man
erreichen durch diese blei kühlung die
sehr viel wärme aufnehmen kann also der
blei strom wird natürlich dann wieder in
einen
wärmetauscher in wasser umgewandelt dass
man turbinen am ende an treibt aber
diese energiedichte ist erstmal in dem
reaktorkern drin und das hat viele
vorteile und ist produziert keinen
zusätzlichen abfall sagen sie sie leben
sonst ja das habe ich nicht gesagt also
das produziert schon abfall aber keine
geologischen zu lagernden abfälle was
kostet das ding ungefähr es ist ja noch
nicht da also es muss noch entwickelt
werden aber wir haben ein team von
ingenieuren physikern und so weiter wie
weit man es immer mehr aus und wir
brauchen für den kommerziellen reaktor
zehn jahre entwicklungszeit da dürfte
der erste prototyp stehen wenn alles gut
läuft da das natürlich schon eine lange
zeit ist haben wir uns überlegt dass man
das prinzip ja erstmal auch in der
realität zeigen muss und dafür haben wir
einen kleinen test reaktor entworfen die
er schon in wenigen jahren ich sage
jetzt mal 2005 25 in betrieb gehen kann
und daher könnte man sie theoretisch die
großstadt berlin ein paar soll als
kleiner gleiches reaktor mit der erst
mal das weil es die leute ja oft nicht
glauben weil das ja so viele vorteile
hat sagen das hier nur auf dem papier
aber sie denken erst mal der rupprecht
steht genau und damit gut wir arbeiten
ja bereits mit mit instituten zusammen
wieder tu dresden tu münchen die
rechnung auch daran rum also die haben
alle nicht gesagt dass wir spinnen also
das ist schon ganz viele andere arten an
so was ihre macht zum beispiel möchte
auch das gerne auf den markt bringen im
moment viele andere in der welt haben
diese idee hat habe ich bei ihnen wenig
schon mal angerufen nein natürlich nicht
natürlich das hätte ich jetzt von einem
grünen nicht erwartet wir haben
überhaupt ich meine wir arbeiten ja
schon zehn jahre dran und das haben uns
ja auch verschiedene parteien eingeladen
die fdp hat es geht ja um die sicherheit
auf dem energiesektor ist im moment das
wichtigste thema in deutschland ja das
wichtigste thema für unseren wohlstand
und sie sagen natürlich hat ja noch
nicht angehört wurde ich habe am haarweg
viel vorzuwerfen aber das jetzt nicht
denn es wäre ja auch keine lösung der
aktuellen krise weil das noch dafür ein
bisschen lange dauert aber es wäre diese
probleme werden ja vermehrt auftreten
denn es ist ja nicht nur putin sondern
das ist die ganze vorgeschichte dass wir
uns überhaupt von wenigen energieträgern
abhängig gemacht haben und wir diese
volatilität von wind und sonne einfach
nicht nicht handhaben können aber sie
müssen im moment ins ausland gehen um
dort weiter zu entwickeln bei haben die
hat noch mal richtig wir haben die firma
letztes jahr in kanada gegründet das hat
viele vorteile aber vor allem dass in
kanada einen die behörden sehr nuklear
offen sind noch mal sehr aufgeschlossen
gegenüber nukleartechnik und das kann
man aber im prinzip überall entwickeln
installieren auch überall war das ja
kleine modulare reaktoren am ende sind
die man dann so ist der gedanke in serie
produziert und ganz nordamerika fährt
schon auf diesen zug also da ist schon
alles auf kleine modulare reaktoren
vorbereitung jetzt ist man ja
ausgestiegen aus der atomkraft damals
gab es große große mehrheit in
deutschland vor allen dingen wegen
fukushima eben das heißt aus
sicherheitsgründen wie gefährlich ist
ihr reaktor also verglichen ja also
fukushima ist ein schlechter vergleich
das wir verlassen uns bei der sicherheit
komplett auf naturgesetze das heißt wir
wenden sehr trickreich naturgesetze an
so dass eine sicherheit ohne externe
einwirkungen entsteht als beispiel das
ganze system ist drucklos im vergleich
zu druckwasserreaktoren haben wir keinen
druck und damit bleiben alle materialien
immer komplett eingeschlossen das ist
eines jetzt ganz plastisch bei sich in
die garage stellen im grunde nur noch
darauf schlafen muss wenn sie soll
strahlt ist natürlich aber da muss man
schon ein bisschen ab oder würden sie
sagen der spinnt rechnen ich kann das
nicht beurteilen denn ich bin ich bin
kein physiker und sein kann was ich
beurteilen kann ist das in deutschland
administrativ verordnet vor als zehn bis
15 jahren alles alles weitere nachdenken
über kein energie gegner quasi
behördlich verboten wurde damit haben
wir einen einen gigantischen vorsprung
den wir in der welt hatten haben wir
aufgegeben und jetzt bin ich bin ich
menschen wie ihnen dabei die aber
gleichwohl ihren verstand nicht
abschalten obwohl sie deutsche sind hier
und an der sache und alle sache
weiterhin sitzen berliner den treiben
wenn der kanal dass das ist das hier
wollte ich natürlich völlig absurd aber
versuchen sie mal in meiner ehemaligen
partei der spd oder oder oder bei der
linkspartei
oder bei den grünen irgendeine eine
diskussion zu staaten über kernenergie
das funktioniert nicht sie wollen
menschen die wirklich noch weniger
ahnung haben als ich wie gesagt ich bin
ökonom und ich kann zahlen lesen das
kann ich das sofa und die noch weniger
ahnung haben als ich würd ja behauptet
dass das dinge gehen die nicht gehen und
dass dinge nicht gehen die gehen muss
sich das mal vorstellen
die gesamte sonnen und windenergie trägt
im augenblick 4,4 prozent zu unserer
erinnerte dabei ganz gut 400 ja und amen
sagen jetzt haben wir hatten wir schon
vor der ukraine einem plan wo man sagt
in zehn jahren soll sie 100 prozent
beitragen das war schon mal hier erlaubt
alle 22 jetzt gar nicht nur noch für ihn
auch jetzt war dem beispiel von den
rupprecht und stellen fest der geht ins
ausland der muss nach kanada gehen um
sein unternehmen zu gründen es ist ein
trauerspiel für die ganze politik egal
welche farbe sie vermasseln dass die
köpfe gehen weg entwickeln dort dort ist
die energie sicherheit gewährleistet und
wir sitzen im dunkeln sowie innovation
auch in deutschland wir müssen als
deutschland auch ein technologie land
bleiben ich werde ja jahren rupprechter
viel erfolg auf seinem weg ja das ist so
eine frage weil sich auch das ist ein
bisschen schneller geht ja sehen jahre
aber ich hoffe dass dieser weg
erfolgreich sein aber auch kein physiker
das verbindet uns weil wir aber ich
hoffe trotzdem dass sie erfolgreich sein
moment aber ich muss noch mal anmerken
die die die anzahl der menschen die
deutschland weil es ist gerade bei
weitem nicht so dramatisch wie die zahl
der anzahl die menschen die russland
verletzt
aber es gibt jetzt geht jetzt hier um
ganz konkreten verspielt man noch
wunderbar aber nicht wir können nicht
her sie sind sofort ran herr klassen und
wenn ich das höre ihre sätze sie haben
jetzt eine schwierige position weil sie
jetzt einmal alles würde regierung hier
ab krieg alles für den nötigen
politischen abkriegen der sax oder so
entlarvend auf herrn rupprecht sagen sie
wir hoffen und wünschen ihnen viel glück
kanada stimmt das glauben wir
haben qualitäten die grundlagenforschung
machen wir haben auch in deutschland
unternehmen die glücklicherweise in
forschung und entwicklung investieren
wolle was in deutschland manchmal vielen
wollen die dass das ist aber nicht das
risikokapital solche unternehmen dann
auch zu unterstellen aber sie wollen den
politisch ja nicht haben das ist ja das
was er sein wissen ob es braucht
ideal comcom fast komplett aus
deutschland was wir bisher eingenommen
hat klarkomme 5 millionen euro und hätte
es gibt viele leute die sind bereits
machen bei dem mann der so lange in der
energiepolitik ist und jetzt aber sagt
für alle fehler in der energiewirtschaft
möchte ich mich aktuell auch nicht
verbauen lassen völlig zu recht der
klasse aber wenn sie das jetzt hören ist
das spinnen oder würden sie sagen bei
herrn rupprecht
sei also also hoher respekt herr
rupprecht an dem thema arbeiten andere
auch ging zuletzt von mehreren
unternehmen angesprochen worden die in
dem bereich investoren suchen die
schwerpunktmäßig aus nordamerika kommen
aus den usa und aus kanada war und es
ist völlig richtig dass die kernenergie
weltweit eine wachstumsbranche und nicht
eines umfangs bange ist man muss sich
mal vorstellen dass in den vereinigten
arabischen emiraten vor nicht langer
zeit das größte kernkraftwerk der welt
in betrieb genommen wurde allerdings
inzwischen mit koreanischer technologie
und nicht mehr mit siemens technologie
und sie selbst das ist alles in
deutschland der klare street band auch
deutschland sehr bedauerlich und das
nämlich einst hinzufügen und ich glaube
da schließt sich der kreis von herrn
sarrazin über herrn rupprecht und mich
zur frau lindemann was frau lienemann
ihr ford legt macht ein jahr sehr
betroffen und im grunde zahlen die
anständigen menschen an der basis die in
deutschland ihre gute arbeit leisten dem
kreis für eine verfehlte ideologisierung
in allen bereichen unserer politik ja
wir müssen mal lernen dass wir nicht
allein aus deutschland den klimaschutz
der welt gestalten können wir müssen mal
lernten dass wir einzelne in der
energiepolitik gehen sollten und als das
exportabhängige land oder eines der
export abhängigen länder der welt nicht
alleingänge wie einen
kernenergieausstieg gestalten können wir
müssen übrigens auch lernen und auch da
hat frau lindemann ja einiges zugesagt
dass wir auch nicht das sozialamt für
die welt sein können und uns auch mal
von der vorstellung verabschieden müssen
dass wir die wir uns inzwischen also nur
noch mit dem waschlappen waschen wollen
dass wir noch für den rest der welt das
sozialamt sein können und andere zu
neuen wohlstand so gezogen führen können
aber nicht mehr wissen wie unsere
eigenen leute über den winter kommen
sollen das ist klar das ist klartext von
uns klassen und das was eben aktuell der
politik ein feld sind dann ratschläge
wie wir durch herbst und winter kommen
können wie wir einsparen sollen und das
sind die worte von daniel günther
aktuell cdu ministerpräsident in
schleswig holstein der sogar sagt er
könnte sich heitz obergrenzen wie ich
jetzt mal ne ne für private haushalte
vorstellen also dass eine maximale
temperatur im herbst und winter
vorgeschrieben wird gesetzlich oder per
verordnung für privathaushalte sarrazin
ja das ist natürlich ein wunderbares
arbeitsbeschaffungsprogramm dann kommt
man in das haus sarrazin und geht von
zimmer zu zimmer und sagt schlafzimmer
ist jetzt ist jetzt 15 grad hier als
hier ist hier 16,5 ordnungsverfügung ja
wohnzimmer ist jetzt 18 grad 19 grad
ordnungsverfügung ja und das bei
35 millionen haushalten in deutschland
ja dass das funktioniert ja überhaupt
gar nicht und vielleicht bin ich bin ich
ein alter mensch und der arzt hat mir
verschrieben weil ich alt bin und
lungenkranke sich bei 25 grad leben
musste ärztliche bescheinigung oder
anderswo anderen wollen keine kinder
oder es gibt einfach menschen diesen
diesen empfindlicher als andere schon
meine frau hat andere temperatur
vorstellung als er aber was wird denn
wir die größte zimmer beziehen können
ist so schon zeitig machen ja aber war
es ja genauso da hätte man nicht von
anfang an die hätte man darüber gelacht
wenn gesagt wird ich kontrolliere oder
das ordnungsamt kontrolliert am abend
wie viele leute privat zu besuch kam ja
genau das ist gekommen und das hat auch
ihre partei in weiten teilen mit
getragen also das heißt auch ordnungsamt
das rum geht und zumindest guckt ob die
ladentüren wie er habe das will dann
geschlossen sind das wird kommen mit
ihrer koalition mit der ampel also ich
halte nichts davon bei den leuten zu
hause vorbei zu gehen und gucken wie
warm es ist aber sie machen es mit am
ende nein nein ich würde ja auch nicht
passieren wer soll denn die 35 millionen
haushalte kontrollieren das wird
natürlich so nicht passieren
ich meine es ist ja auch jeder der
entscheidet dass es zuhause wärmer
unterschreibt
in der verantwortung gewesen aber höhere
heizkosten zu zahlen aber herr faber wir
haben das doch längst wir haben doch die
verordnung die beschlussvorlage aus dem
hause habeck aus dem
wirtschaftsministerium wenn die
durchkommt wird es verordnung werden
dass die ladentüren nicht mehr offen
stehen dürfen dass man die sauna nicht
mehr an machen darf das private putz
verboten werden und das muss
kontrolliert werden durch das
ordnungsamt ja das wird ja alles so gar
nichts passieren wenn übernehmen und
laune gehen will dann geht er seinen
dafür hat er vielleicht anderswo weniger
strom ausgaben und demnächst werden die
heimfahrt fernseher verbrauchen wir
brauchen ja mehr als schwarz weiß gerät
erscheint daran schließen daraus dass
das kommt ja dass das organ salons
kontrolliert ich glaube das szenario
dass der sarrazin gerade dargestellt hat
ist so unrealistisch helfen das so nicht
kommen wird das ist genauso sie glauben
es wird nicht kommen sie schließen es
nicht aus ja es kann jetzt hier auch ein
asteroid einschlagen
was wird was wird in schwedt passieren
wenn all diese verordnung kommt wie wird
die stimmung auf der straße sein und
wenn das ordnungsamt ich spiele dieses
szenario bewusst einmal weiter wenn das
ordnungsamt künftig in der fußgängerzone
kontrolliert ob die ladentüren
geschlossen oder geöffnet sind ich hoffe
dass es ein heißer herbst wird und ein
heißer winter dass die leute auf die
straße gehen und der regierung zeigen
dass er nicht einverstanden sind mit
dieser regierung ich dachte sie meist
jetzt lösen wir diese ganz kurze worte
dieses klima diese stimmung in
deutschland auf wie finden wir
zueinander und wie lösen wir diese
brutale gaskrise die uns wohlstand
kostet den gaskrise kann man durch diese
sogenannte streckung also eigentlich
eine laufzeitverlängerung erst mal
kurzfristig langfristig muss man
technologieoffen sein das heißt es
reicht eben nicht gas und wind und sonne
sondern man muss ein bisschen mehr tun
muss auch wieder offen sein zum beispiel
für um
2.3 sparen sparen sparen wo stehen sie
nein ich wurde nicht sparen sie würden
nicht statt 9 ich sehe keinen grund für
sparen und das bringt doch nicht hat mal
jemand ausgerechnet wie viel dieses mit
dem waschlappen waschen nun überhaupt
sparen und das steht diese woche an die
rechtmäßigen wir vielleicht können sie
helfen beim rechnen sie können das am
allerbesten das hängt davon ab wie auch
der waschlappen gereinigt wird wir
danken herzlich dass das so bleibt ostia
kretschmann ihn was klappen dann in die
waschstraße tut um ihn wieder ruft er
klar von außen reisen wir sind sehr sehr
gespannt danke für die laute streitbare
runde hierbei bild die richtigen fragen
danke einer klassen vollendet man herrn
pfarrer rupprecht unter sarrazin wir
sehen uns nächste woche wieder hier bei
bild die richtigen fragen
[Musik]